we are watching history repeat itself
what we're seeing today is president
zielinski who put it right on the table
when he said quote the world's most
powerful forces are watching from afar
and putin's ego must be so inflated
because he's got the western world bowed
down as he as a political thug goes in
to attack a sovereign nation and the
west is just kind of like oh i don't
know what we'll do maybe we'll sanction
this maybe we'll sanction that and the
truth is this isn't a movie it looks
like a movie but these are real people
who are dying these are real people who
have been begging us as we watch them
line up the troops and the tanks and the
blood and the temporary hospitals and
every day we saw what they were
what they were getting ready to do and i
get that zielinski didn't want to panic
his people i get that he didn't tell
them you know it's time to get out but
right now
this is about raw power it's not about
religion it's not about people who hate
each other it's about a a thug who wants
the russian empire back and you know
what the idea that the united states is
today buying 500 000 barrels of oil from
this thug and allowing him to make money
that allows him then to fight this war
is disgusting and i'm going to add one
more thing i got to keep going hang on
the bottom line is that biden doesn't
want to disrupt the
the russian energy exports and we could
have done it with the keystone pipeline
and this is all a setup and he's talking
about he doesn't want the americans to
suffer in the end the americans are
suffering and the ukrainians are
suffering hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else